mon paradis c'est ça
à voir tous vos yeux braqués sur moi
tous les soirs antennes dans 5 4 3
bonsoir à tous ce soir à tout ce soir à
tous
[Musique]
oui je suis le roi
sarr du paf producteurs
[Musique]
je suis tout simplement indéboulonnable
je vous aime tous
antenne dans huit secondes nous informer
chaque soir et annule en sonar nom et en
plaisir aussi
les audiences de votre jt ne vous
protégeront pas indéfiniment
il m'impressionnait passe à guérande ça
viendra
[Musique]
et rock % de parts de marché hier soir
non danse de joie retrouvée - les
failles de suisse depuis encore 1 ce
matin le coût du cercueil quand même pas
s'il monte dedans vous regardez trop les
infos qu'est ce que vous voulez qui
m'arrive c'est bien kahn a encore qui
vont dire que ça me ressemble mais moi
je dis a plutôt une femme
le neurologue qui peut se comporter
comme ça je crois que j'ai ma petite
idée
[Musique]